bilal ya un titre dans ton dernier album
s'appelle tome 1 qui parle du
harcèlement c'est un titre très
important pour toi je le sais et c'est
vrai que tu dis donc critiquer beaucoup
à l'école pour ton apparence et c'est
vrai que ce soir je voulais qu'on parle
aussi de sa de ce qui se passe avec les
réseaux de ce qui se passe en cour parce
que voilà et il ya plein de jeunes qui
nous regarde on est peut-être le
talk-show plus regardée par les jeunes
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce titre
il est important tome il tu lis que les
gens voulaient de coller une étiquette
alors que tu avais à peine 12 ans oui en
réalité de même plutôt plutôt avec lala
le sujet avec tom c'est même plus
spécialement de parler de mon cas mais
d'utiliser le recul que j'ai sur moi
seulement à l'école pour pour essayer
d'apporter quelque chose pour pour qu'on
arrête ce fléau qu'est le harcèlement
scolaire
donc comme c'est le début d'une grande
mission g
j'ai parlé avec des personnes du
gouvernement on commence enfin à ouvrir
un petit peu des portes et on va on va
mettre des choses en place pour pour
éradiquer ça parce que surtout
aujourd'hui ce qui est grave et on le
sait plus que quiconque avec les nas et
que le harcèlement scolaire
il n'existe plus juste à l'école il
existe aussi quand on rentre à la maison
sur l'exemple snapshots hurler les
groupes facebook et madame yade et du
harcèlement à l'école le moment où tu
rentres chez toi n'est plus le moment où
tu es dans ton cocon c'est le moment où
ça ça empire où ça même des passes des
passes des limites qu'il fasse et ça
c'est très très grave
ou alors banaliser la méchanceté enfin
moi les nattes aussi tu dis que tu as
subi le harcèlement à l'école au collège
à cause de ton apparence notamment à
cause de tes cheveux bouclés c'est quoi
si tu dois cesser en fait c'est chacun
avait son petit truc quoi c'était anaky
son petit lien en question de rayhana
qui sont trop maigres avec sont trop
gros selon les autres et à moi c'est les
cheveux bouclés
c'était mon plus gros complexe maman pas
envoyons disais qu à l'école on disait
rien on s'en moquait tout simplement je
m'attache et les cheveux très très
plaqués et je vais en chignon et les
filets dans la courbe m'arracher à le
les cheveux enfin le chignon le chouchou
pour que mes cheveux face et c'était la
grande blague de tout le monde mais
c'est vraiment l'heure chacun son petit
truc et c'est fou c'est qu'on a vraiment
banaliser la méchant c'est parce que
plus tu es tu es méchante ptt drôle et
je pense que si on aujourd'hui on en
parle aussi ouvertement c'est parce que
c'est vraiment avec le recul on est
tellement dans le truc tu en a pas tant
que ça arrive à tout le monde on s'était
tous un peu harcelé par ci par là et en
fait c'est en recul en prenant de l'âge
je faisais mais c'est pas mal non pas
dans ton va traiter c'est pas normal que
le corps enseignant est ce que vous
dites quoi quand tu étais là bas tu te
rendais pas compte en fait certes ces
quelques années après tu t'es dit mais
c'est vrai que tu dis mais aussi les
profs ne faisait rien pourquoi la cpe
n'en a pas pas étudié mais moi je passe
mes enfants et ça plus douala par l'ate
est professeur à l'époque où même pas ma
mère l'avait fait à ma mère qu'il avait
ma mère alors rodez comme ça ben allal
et toi tu vas venir ici je t'explique
non si on va les trouver
un hacker qui a fait quoi sapelli
vraiment que ça veut dire très bon c'est
vraiment pas pour un truc est aussi
futiles que des cheveux et c'est
vraiment genre - c'était moi c'est allé
c'était beaucoup trop dessus sur les
réseaux sur les réseaux si vous avez
vous avez subi quelques voilà quelques
moqueries quatre hits quelques heures
seulement au vote était victime de
harcèlement sur ton corps l'ena
notamment après à la suite d'un tweet
étudie les exemples de messages reçus
t'as pas honte
j'ai des potes qui ont plus de cinq fois
ton mec te laisse sortir comme ça qu'est
ce que ça ça s'appelle non pas du tout
aujourd'hui ça me peine pas parce que ça
me rend pas très samo same same as
révolte ac c'est plus le côté où j'avais
posté une robe avec un fort décolleté
pique nique très simple mais très belle
robe elle est trop jeune et la
magnifique c'est l'alchimie nature la
petite photo puis de rentrer chez moi et
je vois qu'il ya eu juste pas pourquoi
sur ce poste là en particulier une vague
de commentaires
par rapport à ma petite poitrine est-ce
que j'ai pas apprécié bon ce qui avait
aussi des femmes qui sont rentrés dans
le truc et je me suis un vrai donc si on
commence à tous les membres et au delà
de ça c'est que on m'a on ramène ça aux
hommes de ma vie
ton père est dit quoi tomber ceux sortis
quoi mais moi qu'est ce que je dis c'est
moi qui la portent la robe c'est mon
corps c'est ce que je raconte moi donc
c'est ça qui m'énerve plus et tu avais
dit il ya un climat trop chou
sur twitter où s'est démocratisée d'être
trop méchant mathieu en plus tu es
méchant [ __ ] et drôle pluta dr
et mieux c'est l'ambiance horrible et
c'est bon parce qu'on adore twitter
c'est là c'est drôle mais c'est comme ça
que j'ai laissé le vrai conscient que
direct avec le public c'est comme ça
qu'on peut vraiment leur merci aux
badauds aussi owen vraiment mais vous
savez combien d'abonnés sur twitter
savez vous tournez oui voilà mais en
tout cas pour vous et toi et toi
bilal toi c'est vrai que voilà toi aussi
sur twitter tu tu fais ça sa peine ce
qui fût ce que tu veux ce qu'on peut
dire sur toi sur twitter ou alors ça me
plaît beaucoup plus avant qu'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'avant j'avais un vrai
problème où tu es où je me faisais du
mal à moi même c'est à dire que j'allais
constamment chercher mon nom voir s'il y
avait des choses qui se disait sur moi
je me réveiller le matin ou des fois au
milieu de la nuit avec des sueurs
froides à monza ils ont certainement en
train de dire un truc sur moi il faut
que j'aille à vérifier ben moi j'ai pu
passer un petit peu outre sa et donc des
fois je suis plus sur twitter du tout
maintenant j'ai délégué un petit peu ça
me fait beaucoup de bien
la boue coup et pour les proches ces
certificats étaient proches qui
noircissent et ça l'a dit alors ils sont
sûrs ils sont sur les réseaux sociaux et
regarde ce qu'on dise ce qu'on dit vous
mouais bah c'est vrai elle elle vous dit
des fois il ya des gens qui m'a dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il est méchant celui là
ouais c'est ça elle a envie de alors
bien décédé mp à tout le monde connaît
la réponse c'était un coup de génie pop
qui changeait afro de professer on a la
même tête
c'est grillé que c'est votre mère direct